[Music]
if you don't have anything to look up to
you don't have anything to do right a
lot of the meaning that people find in
their lives is Purpose Driven and in
order to put effort into something to
work towards something you have to
assume axiomatically that what you're
working towards is better than what you
have because why else would you do it
and there's a relationship like if it's
way better than what you have it's
obviously proportionally difficult so
you try to balance difficulty with with
positivity let's say something like that
but you're always aiming up if you're
aiming and if you're not aiming then you
don't really have any purpose and that
deprives your life of meaning that's not
good because if your life is deprived of
meaning then what you're left with is
the suffering it's not neutral right
it's negative so now the problem with
having to aim up is that that produces a
hierarchy right because if you pause it
an aim then everyone arrays themselves
along a hierarchy of better at it to
worse at it right and it doesn't matter
like if you if you create basketball as
a game a hundred years later you create
people who are hyper specialized at
basketball and they're great at it and
virtually everyone else is bad so it
doesn't matter as soon as you produce a
value value proposition you produce a
hierarchy the problem with the hierarchy
is it produces inequality the problem
with inequality is it produces
resentment right but you can't get rid
of the damn hierarchy because they
produce inequality and resentment
because then you don't have anywhere to
go so that's not an answer ok so let's
say you're trying to deal with the fact
that you have to put up with a hierarchy
if you're gonna have any values how do
you escape from the resentment trap an
answer is you do an intelligent
multi-dimensional analysis of your life
it's like by the time you're 30 I would
say you're a pretty singular person you
know your your your unique in particular
and your life has multiple dimensions
and you're more or less successful or
not along many of those demands
but it's completely ridiculous game to
pick someone else arbitrarily who's
doing much better than you on one of
those dimensions to assume that you're a
failure because of that or that the
world is unfair because of that without
knowing in full detail all of the rest
of the elements of their lives
I mean look we're absolutely awash in
stories of unhappy celebrities you know
in admired in interminable divorces or
in in Affairs or in addictions or and
that's par for the course it's not
helpful it's helpful to have a goal it's
necessary to have a hierarchy it's not
particularly useful to compare yourself
to other people
but it is useful to compare yourself to
yourself that's the right baseline right
that stakes everything is else into
account and and it's really practically
useful and I've done this in my clinical
practice very frequently it's like okay
let's take stock of where you are okay
and then let's let's hypothesize about
where you would like to be it's a
complex conversation right because we
want to figure out what's not so good
about your present situation exactly
precisely and then come up with a
hypothesis about what your life would
look like if it was better and then we
can work on incremental improvement and
the idea would be there's some step you
could take that you would take that
would make today or tomorrow
fractionally better than yesterday right
and then you can iterate that and that's
actually unbelievably powerful you you
hit the effect of compounding interest
let's say very very rapidly if you do
that yeah well so there's real utility
and incremental progress and you don't
have to improve your life much in
increments to start hitting the effect
of compounding interest you know you
make one thing slightly better and that
increases the probability that you'll
make the next thing slightly better as
well as having its positive side effects
and so if you even if you make small
steps forward and you do that regularly
that can turn your life around very
rapidly over like a one to two year
period I mean that's a long time one to
two years but it's not a lifetime and it
certainly beats the hell out of going
downhill precipitously which tends to be
the alternative
so it's better and it keeps you out of
the resentment you know it's also more
realistic because it's not like it's not
like everyone else doesn't have their
problems you know we have these
fictitious successful people that that
it's easy for us to compare ourselves to
detrimental II and to become jealous and
bitter about that but also to be very
hard on ourselves because we're not
successful it's like if you talk to
successful people let's say and I'm not
trying to say that there's no such thing
as genuine accomplishment because
obviously there is but people even
people who are successful have dipped
lives that are very difficult and you
know they have a ill family member or
agent parents or or they're suffering
from some serious illness themselves
which is very very common or they have a
psychological problem that's not trivial
or they have a traumatic past it's like
life is brutal and and becoming
resentful about your relative position
is a way to make it more brutal it's not
helpful to you and it's not helpful to
anyone else
[Music]
you